Світ бореться з пандемією коронавірусу, який, за різними оцінками,
може заразити від 20 до 60 відсотків населення планети і вбити десятки мільйонів людей.
Як протидіяти цій загрозі? Вірусологи говорять про три стратегії боротьби.
Це найбільш жорсткий, але й найпослідовніший варіант.
Країни закривають свої кордони і намагаються повністю ізолюватися.
Літаки не літають, роботу наземного транспорту, як і громадського обмежено або призупинено.
Закрито магазини, підприємства, кафе і ресторани.
На вулицю дозволено виходити лише за продуктами, ліками
і на роботу в критично важливих галузях для забезпечення життєдіяльності країни.
Цим шляхом пішла, зокрема, Італія.
Щоправда, як зазначають експерти, зі значним запізненням.
Тому більша частина інших країн Європи, не чекаючи, доки ситуація вийде з-під контролю,
теж пішли шляхом суворого карантину для всіх.
Перевага суворого карантину в тому, що в ідеалі, якби всі дотримувалися жорстких обмежень,
то вірус фізично не зміг би поширюватися і за лічені тижні міг би зникнути, вважають деякі вірусологи.
Утім, втілити такий абсолютний карантин на практиці майже неможливо.
Головним недоліком цієї стратегії є шалені економічні збитки,
які відчують на собі всі верстви населення:
від власника кав’ярні чи невеликого бізнесу до транснаціональних корпорацій та авіакомпаній.
Німецькі економісти вже нині прогнозують, що світ буде оговтуватися від економічних наслідків
карантинних заходів ще 10 років.
Це найбільш ліберальний, якщо не сказати легковажний варіант, який, по суті,
полягає в тому, щоб дати вірусу розвиватися своїм природним шляхом.
Прихильники такого сценарію виходять з того, що коронавірус у 80 відсотках випадків
і так протікає в легкій формі.
Після того, як 60-70 відсотків населення перехворіють цим вірусом,
виробиться колективний імунітет.
Чим більшою буде група людей з імунітетом - тим меншим буде ризик,
що вірус пошириться на літніх людей чи людей зі слабким здоров’ям.
Такого сценарію спершу дотримувалися Великобританія і Нідерланди.
Прем’єр-міністр Нідерландів Марк Рютте у своїй промові до нації навіть проводив паралелі з епідемією кору,
мовляв, як і з цією хворобою, за допомогою групового імунітету навколо вразливих верств населення
буде сформована так звана "умовна захисна стіна".
Утім, згодом ці країни також перейшли до жорсткіших заходів протидії коронавірусу. Чому?
Звісно, перевага такого сценарію в тому,
що економіка і суспільство продовжують функціонувати.
Однак такий сценарій вельми ризикований, адже ситуація може
миттєво вийти з-під контролю, застерігають у Всесвітній організації охорони здоров'я.
Річ у тім, що поки що ніхто достеменно не знає, коли і як швидко сформується груповий імунітет.
Знань про поведінку цього вірусу ще надто мало.
До того ж, за оцінками вірусологів, поки формуватиметься груповий імунітет,
кількість померлих від коронавірусу в Нідерландах може сягнути від 40 до 80 тисяч людей.
А система охорони здоров’я не витримає навантаження, і ці країни
ризикують повторити долю Італії, попереджають експерти.
Тим часом в Японії, приміром, досі не вдаються до жорстких карантинних заходів.
Тут намагаються максимально швидко ідентифікувати хворих, негайно ізолювати їх
та відстежувати ймовірні контакти.
У Токіо до останнього вірили,
що японцям таки вдасться провести Олімпійські ігри влітку цього року.
Є ще третій, на перший погляд, простий сценарій -
відправити на суворий карантин лише групи ризику та людей похилого віку.
За такого сценарію, економіка працювала б далі
і негативні наслідки для бізнесу не були б такими велетенськими.
А груповий імунітет вироблявся б швидше, ніж за умов строгого "шат-дауна".
Утім, на практиці зробити це дуже складно.
Будинки для літніх людей убезпечити можна,
але масово ізолювати усіх пенсіонерів та людей з хронічними захворюваннями
неможливо, стверджують експерти.
До того ж постає питання, як довго повинні самоізолюватися групи ризику?
Декілька тижнів? Місяців?
Адже навіть після тривалої самоізоляції ризик заразитися
все одно існуватиме - вірусологи говорять про термін у рік-півтора, коли вдасться подолати вірус.
Крім того, з правової точки зору, цей сценарій неможливий, адже порушує базові права людини.
Як пояснити літнім людям, що їм не можна ходити до перукаря чи на концерти
або елементарно виходити на вулицю і зустрічатися зі своїми дітьми та внуками?
До того ж, як визначити категорії, кого саме ізолювати?
65 років - то на карантин, а якщо 64 з половиною - то вже не в групі ризику?
Німецька влада переконана, що не можна розділяти суспільство
і що подолання кризи коронавірусу - це суспільна солідарна відповідальність.
У демократичних країнах найвищою цінністю є людина та її життя,
збереження якого має пріоритет над економічними вигодами чи втратами.